في تطور غير مسبوق فوق مياه البحر الاسود
اعلن المتحدث
فقدان مسيره امريكيه من طراز ام كيو 9 بعد
اصطدام مقاتله روسيه بها فوق البحر الاسود
واشار رايدر في مؤتمر صحفي الى ان المسيره
كانت تقوم بمهمه استطلاع فوق المياه
الدوليه حين اعترضتها مقاتلتان روسيتان من
طراس سوخوي بطريقه غير مهنيه وخطيره حسب
قوله واضافنا احدى المقاتلتين اصطدمت
بالمسيره مطره القوه الامريكيه الى
اسقاطها
ما رايناه هو قيام طائره مقاتله بالقاء
الوقود امام هذه المسيره ومن ثم الاقتراب
منها لدرجه انها تسببت بالفعل في اتلاف
المروحه الموجوده على مسيره ام كيو 9
نعتقد ان ذلك تسبب على الارجح في الحاق
بعض الاضرار بالطائره الروسيه ايضا نعلم
ان الطائره الروسيه هبطت في احد الاماكن
لكنني لن اعلن اين بالضبط وهذا الامر يشكل
دليلا على الانعدام معايير المهنيه
والسلامه لدى اولئك الطيارين
هذا النوع من المسيرات مجهز لحمل اسلحه
لكنه لم يؤكد ما اذا كانت المسيره التي تم
اسقاطها تحمل ذخيره ام لا واكتفى المتحدث
باسم البنتاغون
بالتاكيد انها طائره استطلاعيه دون
الافصاح عن مهمتها
بعينها سيكتفي بالقول انها منصه مراقبه
واستطلاع وبسبب الضرر الذي لحق بها اضطرنا
الى اسقاطها في البحر الاسود وعلى حد علمي
حتى الان لم ينتشر الروس تلك المسيره اما
فيما يتعلق بجهودنا بشان انتشالها فلا
املك اي تفاصيل في هذه المرحله